notre protocole n'avait qu'une seule
option la greffe j'ai commencé à lui
expliqué petit à petit qu'on allait
sûrement trouver un donneur sanaa
quand on se met à la place du patient
on comprend ce que ça fait d'apprendre
qu'il y ait un donneur potentiel mais
que soudain ce donneur a disparu
au début je n'avais aucune idée de ce
que c'était j'ai réfléchi pendant une
dizaine de minutes
j'ai d'abord eu peur j'ai même pensé à
refuser
si on calcule le nombre de patients
morts faute de donneur compatible
faute de greffe on est à peu près à 3 à
4000 personnes par an en russie
c'est la réalité
ou aux commandes
nous nous promenions près de l'académie
de ballet russe
c'est la référence de la danse classique
et là nous avons vu une annonce
auditions pour les filles de 10 ans
certaines de ces filles candidates
étaient plus encouragés à persévérer par
les professeurs par pour brad on
prédisait à karina soldats tova une
brillante carrière de danseuse de ballet
l'une des meilleures étudiante de
l'académie vaganova elle était déjà
demandé par le théâtre mariinsky il ne
restait qu'un nom avant la fin de ses
études
c'est alors que karina a commencé à
avoir des problèmes de santé
il ya eu des fractures inexplicable le
traitement ne réussissait pas une fois
que la jambe guérie elle se casser à
nouveau
pourtant les analyses de sang étaient
bonnes
elle continuait à aller au cours à cause
de ses fractures elle ne pouvait plus
tout faire à l'académie mais elle a
quand même passer tous ses examens sans
se plaindre
je suis impressionné par ce qu'elle a
accompli il s'est avéré plus tard qu'au
moment où karine à passer ces épreuves
sa maladie la leucémie s'étaient déjà
installés
nous à celui dont nous avons trouvé un
donneur et karine a reçu une greffe puis
un certain moment elle a senti que
quelque chose n'allait pas j'ai des
tâches qui apparaissent des et lgd tâche
sur mon corps et là on a tiré une
sonnette d'alarmé
on a compris que c'était une rechute
elle a développé une infection une
mycose et la mycose se développer plus
rapidement que le système immunitaire
les cellules sanguines n'ont pas eu le
temps de se régénérer et j'ai perdu ma
petite karine avons bien sûr que quand
on revient sur le passé sur ce qu'elle a
vécu
il est clair qu'elle avait une leucémie
et bien sûr ça a été une tragédie
je vais vous montrer ma petite karine à
ces les petits moments simples d'une
mère de regarder en fait l'enfant est
toujours là il est toujours avec nous
comme avant voilà ma petite kahina
[Musique]
gome
je n'en peux plus vous avez encore
besoin de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le goutte à goutte
là c'est un cathéter
[Musique]
c'est la transfusion pour une fille de 7
ans les rats connais beaucoup trop de
choses sur les perfusions les cathéters
et les transfusions et trop peu sur la
vie hors de l'appartement et des
hôpitaux
la maladie qui l'a séparé du reste du
monde s'est manifestée peu avant le jour
où elle devait aller à l'école pour la
première fois avant l'école les rats est
allé deux semaines dans un centre de
santé spécialisés en gastro la
directrice a remarqué des bleus sur son
corps et l'a envoyée pour un test
sanguin général plusieurs indicateurs
étaient déjà bas on l'a immédiatement
admise à l'hôpital régional au
département d'oncologie la maladie a
tout de suite commencé à se développer
rapidement
le faible nombre de plaquettes provoquer
des ecchymoses sur tout le corps et un
faible taux d'hémoglobine nous a annoncé
de diagnostic potentiel une leucémie ou
une anémie
quand nous avons appris que c'était une
anémie ap la zik j'ai été soulagé mais
le médecin m'a dit de ne pas prendre les
choses à la légère car c'est aussi grave
qu une leucémie
il s'est avéré que nous avions une forme
très grave et rare d'année mis à plat
zik très grave c'est quoi ton plus grand
voeu
je tente pas aller à l'école
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi tu ne peux pas y aller
parce que j'étais malade tu veux y aller
vraiment oui
c'est ton bonnet allez ma belle
pour elle aussi c'était dur
psychologiquement d'être dans le service
oncologique
elle demandait pourquoi les enfants
étaient chauds pourquoi quelqu'un avait
mal au coeur quelqu'un vomissait
pourquoi tant d'entre eux pleuraient
je lui ai parlé de la greffe je lui dis
qu'on lui introduirait des cellules de
quelqu'un d'autre et qui après elle
restera à l'hôpital pour se rétablir
nous avons discuté de tout cela elle l'a
compris elle l'accepté maintenant elle
attend un donneur d'abord on cherche un
donneur compatible dans le registre
russe cette base de données réunit tous
ceux qui ont accepté de donner de la
moelle osseuse ou des cellules souches
pour faire partie du registre il faut
passer un test de profil génétique
c'est-à-dire un test spécial d'adr
ensuite le donneur potentiel attend son
sens où sa moelle osseuse peuvent être
requis à tout moment dans une semaine ou
dans 10 ans un cours d'eau dans le
registre de kirov
il y as probablement entre 25 et 28
mille d'honneur dans celui de
petrozavodsk
environ 6000 il y à saint-pétersbourg un
registre qui compte aussi à peu près dix
mille personnes et dans notre registre
de vassia père ricci kof
je dirais que c'est entre 25 et 30 mille
d'honneur le 85 à 90 milles en tournée
est-ce beaucoup ou peu c'est peu et on
s'en rend compte en faisant une
comparaison la russie à 140 millions
d'habitants est moins de 100000 donneurs
potentiels de moelle osseuse alors qu'en
allemagne sur 80 millions d'habitants
9 millions sont des donneurs enregistrés
un habitant sur dix
cette phrase dans les bases de données
du monde entier il y actuellement 36
millions de donneurs mais souvent les
cliniques ne trouve pas de donneur
compatible
c'est pourquoi notre travail est si
important nous recherchons constamment
des donneurs et les ajoutons à notre
base de données
l'un d'entre vous peut avoir les
antigènes h
elle a recherché par des patients à
moscou ou ailleurs cela peut arriver
la recherche d'un donneur ressemble
beaucoup à une loterie
il faut que les chiffres de votre ticket
donné à la naissance votre code adn
l'ensemble des achats là correspond
entièrement à ceux du donneur vous devez
trouver en jumeaux génétique
ça peut être une personne sur dix mille
nous sommes la fondation stéphane marche
une fondation caritative à but non
lucratif dont le principal objectif est
d'aider les patients atteints de
leucémie et de tumeurs
elle porte le nom de mon frère qui a eu
une leucémie en 1983 et qui a été le
premier européen à recevoir une greffe
d'un donneur en dépendant de grande
bretagne
le frère de susan
stéphane est décédé suite à des
complications imprévus mais c'est sa
triste histoire qui est à l'origine
d'une organisation caritative devenu
plus tard une célèbre fondation d'ado
patients atteints de leucémie
nous sommes dans le centre de collecte
de la fondation stéphane marche et dans
ce bâtiment nous prélevons les cellules
du donneur pour les patients du monde
entier
je m'appelle alessandra je viens du
luxembourg je me suis enregistré comme
donneur il ya je crois dix ans j'avais
19 ans à l'époque vous
[Musique]
récemment il ya un peu plus de deux mois
le 6 octobre
on m'a appelé pour me dire nous avons un
patient à qui vous pourriez
potentiellement convenir les membres de
ma famille avait un peu peur se
demandant quels seraient les impacts sur
mon corps il me demandait quelles seront
les conséquences pour ton corps
mais tout le monde m'a soutenu en me
disant oui c'est bien de faire ça c'est
vraiment très digne il existe deux types
de procédures
la plupart des donneurs donne tout
simplement du sang plus précisément des
cellules souches un médicament spéciale
est administrée à l'avance pour stimuler
la production de cellules souches
ensuite le donneur reste assis pendant
quelques heures alors qu'une machine
extrait de son sang les cellules souches
c'est comme ça que cela se passe dans
80% des cas l'autre type de procédure
est beaucoup plus rare et demande
beaucoup de courage
un échantillon de moelle osseuse est
prélevé directement de la hanche sous
anesthésie générale
l'un des principaux objectifs de la
fondation est de promouvoir le don de
cellules souches ce nécessaire parce que
chaque année des milliers de donneurs
sont retirés du registre tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont atteint l'âge limite
nous avons donc constamment besoin de
chercher de nouveaux donneurs pour avoir
le nombre nécessaire dans notre base
très bien visuel est aussi excellent
marach merci de vous êtes inscrit au
registre des donneurs de moelle osseuse
je veux vous rappeler que vous devez
informer leurs augis si vous changez
d'adressé de numéros de téléphone ou du
mail car vous pourriez devenir donneur à
tout moment si en allemagne le système
de donneurs de moelle et réfléchie et
bien élaboré en russie c'est plutôt une
cause de militants la plupart des gens
n'entendent parler du problème que
lorsqu'un proche ou un ami est touché il
commence à chercher un donneur pour une
personne concrètes et finissent par
devenir eux-mêmes militants le
développement du don de moelle a
commencé avec l'histoire de pauline à la
mère de pauline est une collègue paulina
est tombé malade en 2014
nous étions très inquiet pour sa santé
nous sommes allés chez un pédiatre et
avons fait une analyse sanguine
le lendemain on nous a envoyés au
service on coud hématologie de la région
de tcheliabinsk là le diagnostic a été
confirmé
anémie ap la zik
on a appris avec olga qu'il y avait une
chance sur dix mille de trouve un jumeau
génétique il pourrait se trouver
n'importe où dans n'importe quel village
ville dans n'importe quel pays qui sait
où ce jumeau génétique se trouvait olg
et moi avons décidé de créer une vague à
travers toute la russie afin que le plus
de gens possible soit au courant et se
propose il nous fallait qu'au moins dix
mille personnes donnent leur sang la
campagne a pris de l'ampleur des
volontaires de différentes villes des
personnes compatissantes nous ont
rejoint plus de 20 villes ont participé
à la campagne
un donneur pour pauline à 30 civils ont
participé à la journée mondiale des
donneurs
l'histoire de la recherche d'un donneur
pour la petite pauline a parmi les
habitants de millas dans le sud de
l'oural a montré que les citoyens
étaient sensibles et compatissant mais
ils sont peu informés
il faut qu'il y ait plus de militants
comme anastasia pour écrire publier des
articles sur internet
sensibiliser le public il faut que les
gens cessent d'associer le don de moelle
osseuse à l'image d'une aiguille qui
endommagent les épines dorsales
il faut que ce soit un symbole d'espoir
un donneur pour pauline a été trouvé
la greffe a été réalisée fin novembre
[Musique]
la greffe s'est plutôt bien passé nous
attendions la réponse de son corps elle
a eu lieu mais le système immunitaire de
polina était plus fort et la rejeter
maintenant elle a besoin d'une
transplantation de moelle osseuse d'un
parent parce que nous ne pouvons pas
attendre la greffe de quelqu'un qui
n'appartiennent pas à la famille
nous allons au village de mais aussi
chat dans le district de dacca d'ayem
c'est le village d'où viennent de
donneurs de moelle osseuse
roslan rahman gadjev est un exemple rare
originaire du daguestan donneurs de sang
devenu donneurs de moelle osseuse ce
simple mot fait peur à la majorité de
ses proches et voisins de ce petit
village de montagne
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens s'imaginent qu'on brise
les os et qu'on en retire la moelle
quelque chose de terrible
mais quand je leur dis qu'on apprend
dans le sang ils sont soulagés
c'est ici que sont et nos parents nos
grands-parents et nous sommes nés ici et
nous seront enterrés ici avec ou sans
voile
nous saurons quand même enterré ici là
on va à pied
on va traverser le village la voiture ne
passe pas encore une fois il s'agit
d'une loterie vos chances sont bien plus
modestes si vous avez obtenu un ticket
rares à la naissance
si vous venez d'un groupe ethnique qui
n'est pas ou peu représenté dans le
registre
c'est pourquoi il est si important que
des gens comme roux cela ne passe les
tests et soient ajoutés aux bases de
données
trouver un donneur pour les minorités
ethniques est un gros problème
ils sont sous représentées dans les
bases de données internationales et les
recherches peuvent prendre des années et
s'est terminée par un échec
il est difficile de trouver des donneurs
de génotype caucasiens vous pouvez en
trouver n'importe où sauf au daguestan
on cherche des donneurs pour les petits
daguestanais dans le monde entier
de ce que je sais il ya un enfant à
kaspiïsk à qui on a trouvé un donneur de
ont été trouvés en israël mais pas un
seul en russie j'ai moi même rejoint le
registre de don de moelle osseuse
j'ai oublié quand on m'a appelé depuis
kirov pour me demander si j'étais
d'accord
bien sûr j'étais d'accord la moelle
osseuse est principalement donner aux
enfants à kirov
nous avons fait un don avec miroslav
on nous a seulement dit que c'était pour
les enfants détiennent à toronto
on ne m'a pas dit de quelle nationalité
il était de quelle couleur de peau ou de
cheveux rien dommage nous aurons plus
parler et savoir dans quel état elle
enfants mais nous devons encore attendre
un an
[Musique]
en allemagne
tous les registres ainsi que tous les
centres de donneurs communique élaborent
ensemble les règles de protection des
donneurs l'une de ses règles n'autorise
les contacts entre donneur et patients
qu'au bout de deux ans principalement
parce qu'il ya une chance que la maladie
reviennent le patient pourrait donc
demander un deuxième don de ce même
donneur et encore une fois nous ne
voulons pas exercer de pression sur le
donneur si on s'adresse aux donneurs
pour la deuxième fois
il doit avoir la même possibilité de
refuser aux de dire oui je ferai le don
s'ils se connaissent déjà
il n'y a aucune garantie qu'il n'y aura
pas de pression
[Musique]
sade et ce sont des couples donneur
receveur qui se sont rencontrés ici à
birkenfeld regarder leurs visages et
sourires heureux ils sont heureux de se
voir les donneurs peuvent s'assurer que
l'opération a été un succès mais pour
les patients c'est une chance de dire
enfin merci à son donneur mais certains
se rencontrent et discutent échangent
des informations et peuvent ne plus
jamais se revoir dans d'autres cas il ya
des amitiés qui se crée ils deviennent
une famille des amis proches set à
chaque fois différent nous avons
également des donneurs qui disent je ne
veux pas savoir je sais que j'ai fait
tout ce que j'ai pu mais je n'ai pas
besoin de savoir plus pour moi il suffit
de savoir que je lui ai donné une chance
et nous comprenons également si le
patient dit par exemple
non je ne veux pas parce que ça me
rappelle les pires moments de ma vie
cette vidéo par exemple a été filmée
lors de notre dernière rencontre donneur
et receveur la donneuse penser que la
receveuse était toujours aux états unis
et que c'était simplement un appel sur
skype et nous étions avec elle lors de
cet appel nous étions avec elle alors
que la receveuse était dans un bureau à
côté et finit par entrer pour faire une
surprise
[Musique]
on a prélevé un échantillon de moelle
osseuse je les emmenais au centre de
recherche dimitri rogatchev à moscou
pour analyse et là on a diagnostiqué
chez mon fiche une leucémie by
phénotypiques un risque ni héloïse
lymphoblastique t il n'y a pas d'autre
traitement que la transplantation
j'ai été opéré sous anesthésie générale
tout a commencé vers 9 heures après tout
ce dont je me souviens c'est le moment
où les médecins m'ont mis un masque sur
le visage
je me suis réveillé vers 15 heures
l'anesthésié n'avait plus d'effet je me
sentais pas très bien c'est vrai j'avais
une petite tache large mais elle a
disparu maintenant il ne reste même plus
de cicatrices il fait 6 degrés ici à
kaliningrad
il est 15 heures
notre donneur compatible était un jeune
homme du registre de kirov au moment de
la transplantation il avait 25 ans c'est
tout ce que nous savions de lui je
savais seulement que c'était un petit
enfant le reste était anonyme
on m'a dit que ça allait bien que la
moelle osseuse et est compatible que
l'enfant avait survécu
je pense qu'il a lui même voulu
rencontrer l'enfant qui l'a sauvé c'est
un peu une partie de lui maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il a changé
c'était un garçon blond avant et après
l'opération il est devenu tous bruns
maintenant il est châtain même son
comportement a un peu changé tant que ça
change les gens en fait
bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour à vous je suis
riche at je suis et katarina voici
guéorgui ici c'est moi richard à gauche
à ses tons d'honneur qui t'a donné la
moelle osseuse compte à greffer c'est
presque un membre de la famille un homme
n'est il a une famille un homme se marie
il a de nouveau proche et parfois un
homme partage une petite partie de soi
et trouve un frère de sang à l'autre
bout du pays
je suis originaire de kazan au tatarstan
je suis entré au collège d'aviation et
j'ai eu mon diplôme en 2014
je suis devenu d'honneur en août de la
même année ils ont rapporté votre moelle
osseuse ici en avion sous ce qui était
écrit sur le petit sac s'était jeune
homme 25 ans
tout le reste était secret sauf le
registre de kirov
ils ont dit c'est tout ce que vous devez
savoir le médecin a seulement ajouté
qu'ils nous avaient donné de la vraie
moelle osseuse pas des lymphocytes l ai
dit que c'était très bien
il est en rémission maintenant grâce à
vous aujourd'hui riche à de kazan et
gauche à deux sauvette sq tout près de
la frontière russe aux lituaniennes sont
vraiment comme des frères de sang ils
ont désormais le même groupe sanguin le
haut plus de gauche a est devenu le b
plus de richesses
[Musique]
ville à 11 ans maintenant nous vivons
donc avec ça depuis quatre ans nous
avons déjà vu mourir des enfants qui
avait été opéré il ya eu le cas d'une
petite fille qui a demandé à sa maman de
lui acheter un avion légaux sa mère a
demandé à quoi tu serviras un avion elle
a répondu je veux simplement un avion
elle n'a pas acheté la fillette est
morte une semaine plus tard sa mère a
acheté l'avion l' assemblée l'a emporté
au cimetière la mort dans l'âme en dix
ans peut-être que si je l'avais achetée
elle aurait survécu petite rando avec
[Musique]
remuez bien les médicaments ils ont
dissous pour remuer avec une cuillère
à présent sa santé ne dépend que des
transfusions sanguines
nous allons à l'hôpital régional une ou
deux fois par semaine selon ce que nous
dit le médecin pour donner du sang le
médecin fait des tests pour voir si elle
a besoin d'une transfusion elle
transfuse des plaquettes ou du sens pour
augmenter le taux d'hémoglobine et que
les indicateurs montrent et se stabilise
plus ou moins ils nous laissent rentrer
chez nous pour une semaine seuls ces
transfusions maintienne sa santé à
l'heure actuelle salut ça va si bien
c'est le test de biochimie aujourd'hui
de l'aven d'accord t'inquiète tout ira
bien ce n'est pas la première fois ma
petite je veux pas y aller je veux pas y
aller tu ne sais même pas si ce sera de
la vanne ou du doigt maintenant le
médecin va venir et nous dira d'où ces
jeux c'est et comment tu sais que la
veine elle va très bien non non non
donne moi ta main ça va seulement faire
mal pendant une seconde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est triste bien sûr ça nous a terrassé
mon mari a appelé le chef du département
nous avions été traités à la clinique
fédéral nous avions prévu de faire la
greffe là bas il lui a dit qu'il n'y
avait toujours pas de donneurs
potentiels dans la base de données
mondiale
il dit que la recherche est toujours en
cours et nous espérons qu'ils en
trouveront un mais pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
on